do we talk about check-offs gun so
basically the checkups gun is that the
axiom is if there's a gun on the wall
and you mention it you have to use it if
the gun doesn't go off then you've set
up an expectation that you didn't
deliver on and it's a good principle and
again it's one of those principles where
it's like generally speaking you want to
obey it but again look at No Country for
Old Men
they Llewellyn Moss is a loaded gun on
the wall and in the end he fails and it
doesn't we don't get what we expected
but it meant something to the story so
it's like every principle it it helps us
to understand like that the general
principle is that if you're going to
talk about something no detail in any
story should ever be wasted you're
especially with screenwriting you have
you want to be as sparse as possible you
want to be as specific as possible so
when you're writing something you're not
just throwing stuff out there it all has
to be you should regard every single
word as a kind of setup that you now
have a debt to resolve but that said if
you are going to break that rule have a
really good reason for it
No Country for Old Men is the perfect
reason because it directly contributed
to the interpretation of the theme so
even like if you just want to paint you
know it like in novels I think are we
much more apt to someone an author is
gonna paint a world and maybe add little
details but in a screenplay no you're
saying don't don't do too much of that
world because it's it's just I would we
say is into a novel writing oh really
yeah because I mean it really comes down
to you know the the voice the language
and a lot of the times when you're
setting something up you're trying to
plant seeds of something that you don't
want the kit the audience to be paying
attention to because later it pays off
and comes through and you're like oh I
didn't even see that coming but if you
didn't set it up beforehand then it
feels like a cheat when it's suddenly
introduced it really just comes down to
really knowing the craft it's super
specific to the needs of your story
and a lot of that will depend on you
know get it in front of other people see
if it feels like a cheat
see if it feels like you're setting
something up sometimes if you say you
know the laser gun sitting on the table
you're gonna be like wait laser gun are
we in the future you know and those are
things you need to pay attention to and
a lot of that is you know fine-tooth
comb in your script and getting other
people to read it and gauging their
expectations and getting getting as much
feedback as you can
you